>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: YOU MAY HAVE WONDERED
AS DEMOCRACIES MEET THIS WEEK
WHO WILL REPRESENT THE U.S. AT
THE G-7 SUMMIT.
JOE BIDEN CAN'T DO.
KAMALA HARRIS COULD GO BUT SHE
IS GETTING YELLED AT BY
GUATEMALA FARMERS.
WE HAVE A DR. JILL WHO IS NOT
ACTUALLY A DOCTOR.
SHE IS REPAIRING FOR THE G-7.
SHE HAS HER READING GLASSES ON
AND A PEN IN HAND.
HER HUSBAND'S JACKET IS ON THE
CHAIR BEHIND HER.
SITTING AT JOE BIDEN'S DESK AT
AIR FORCE ONE.
DR. JILL IS IN CHARGE NOW.
WHAT IS IN THE BINDER?
WHAT IS SHE READING?
WE HOPE THAT FINALLY AFTER ALL
OF THESE YEARS SHE IS TAKING THE
TIME TO EDITOR DOCTORATE
DISERATION.
HE WAS IN A RUSH THE FIRST TIME
AND THAT INCLUDE MANY TYPOS.
AND UNFORGETTABLE SENTENCES LIKE
THIS ONE:
-- IN OTHER WORDS IN DELAWARE'S
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THEY ARE
ADDRESSING RETENTION.
COULD THERE BE A BETTER WAY TO
SAY IT?
WE WOULD LIKE TO SAY IT THAT
DR. JILL I